hello and welcome to this video and
playing let's see just jokes are not
funny maybe sketch I cannot pronounce it
okay I gotta go to see laughs with
Quincy to okay I feel like feels like I
haven't had this on the board for a
while nowadays people really know the
stuff there you for the e 45 now it's
really a pest em if people study chest
why do why do you do that okay anyway so
yeah this is not great but I don't have
a good recipe against it so let's go for
95 like it's taking bishop you success
is the main line which is equal ok
quindi three I guess or no
yeah as I said this is equal but
currently why doesn't have anything in
that line and I have no big improvement
ready black can play Bishop c5 now for
example that's a good move maybe also
going to be six I go Quincy to
hmm he is taking quite a volume I wonder
if there is something more exciting that
I don't know I don't understand queen
bee six maybe yeah here I have to
probably defend f2 and now Bishop d4
looks looks normal for white yeah so I'm
going to push this away and go to
develop I wonder 95 can I go f4 is that
too loose could be too loose actually
form that unites you for might be
possible I think I'll just continue with
my normal development what white here
still has is that extra or extras may be
wrong but I have that sent upon only
find this can prove useful ok so if I go
F 494 I don't know III is weak
94 94 still s 93 yeah it seems to work
so let's do this first
night a form doesn't lead anywhere
between a five or queen before as
possible and f4 that's still nights you
phone fortunately I cannot go be three
as Quincy five so awkward
don't see something very convincing here
I don't see a convincing doubling on the
key file I'm not sure it doesn't look
very dangerous
okay so takes takes to q1 now
threatening night a 4
I've got 94 tactics em click on c5 next
depends with what is doing here maybe I
have a better move also clean before
lights if I force my idea Queen takes
and b3 then but I can also play Queen
before be 32 ship moves and then notify
it's going there ok ok
it's all about that pin on the default
yeah that's the best move relatively and
probably have to take now here how to do
that I reaction thinking I'd like to do
something here on the dark squares with
a 5 opening up the position v5 takes
root before let's do this oh I didn't
see Bishop f5 this is covering it a
million times that's bad Wow okay that
was a terrible idea time morning hm ok
now I need to get something going on the
dark square that should be possible
clean / 2 g-3 hmm i don't like to trade
probably getting the rook always better
even
Queen g3 coming I prefer going to h4 I
could have taken already but I he cannot
save it anyway check check check check
check check come on that great play
buddy yeah I am yeah i'm just very slow
at the moment i don't know i'm starting
with more time you had to totally
winning position i don't really know
what it is I'm slower than usual maybe
something changed in the way my my hand
mouth coordination is working I know it
sounds be epic just why my desk is also
positioned a little bit differently and
so on I don't know the whole thing it
feels very slow I mean I'm not such a
slow player but it was the only way to
lose that game of the same some some
idiotic time scramble yeah anyway so we
can still have a look it was equal for a
very long time around him um yeah and
not much not much happened it just a
said very equal ish yeah until he until
he played that after which I more or
less winning the game night xe5 yeah if
I've was badly timed I just have to play
that yeah and the computer actually
likes it but I can play whatever B
should be 60 on many moves keep a big
advantage but this wasn't so great I
mean it's still better for me because of
his bad corn structure but there were
simpler ways I should just win I mean
I'm 15 seconds up and totally winning so
it's just very awful to cannot have one
design even yeah
time but I'm just very slow i don't
really know what it is i take a long
time check for just moving it's not like
i'm thinking the move itself takes long
and maybe it's really that i have to
change something about the way I'm
position to add the desk I don't know I
don't know why I'm so slow we even here
okay four seconds check and it is just
making some checks or whatever Snow
Queen III is also quick made but there
was pee moose they were pre moose yeah
anyway thanks for watching